at the same time Russia's now getting
involved hezbollah's commenting Iran's
been involved in this clip he's telling
us all about who is Hamas who is
Hezbollah uh who is Isis even if the
call is to be fair and balanced about
things then look at the whole history of
the conflict if I bring these two
together I should request of you to look
at the whole history and realize that if
you think these are terrorist groups
Israel was initiated and expanded
through terroristic means before being
an official Nation by almost in a sense
bullying the British into uh reenacting
their B for declaration which many
people don't realize the British
actually took it back the B for
declaration and released a white paper
that said no no no no we're not having a
Jewish state only 75,000 Jews and then
the rest is guess is going to be a
regular State mixed with whoever lives
there the hag is a terrorist group they
were meant to defend uh the Jews they
started as a militia in Palestine and
then they started blowing things up
including the base where the British
were so by any legal definition it's
also a terroristic group